okay so the batman has one of my
favorite opening half hours in a comic
book movie ever that's some high praise
and you only have to look at the opening
scenes in the dark knight trilogy to
know that reeves had some very steep
competition christopher nolan was an
expert at introducing the villains and
though reeves does that brilliantly with
the riddler 2 the scene in which he
brings in his version of batman is a
whole nother level but why is it so
captivating and what does the director
do to give us the best introduction to
the batman that we've ever had well
that's what we're going to be breaking
down in this video so hold on to your
bats hit that thumbs up button and make
sure you subscribe for videos like this
every day without the way i'm your host
paul aka the guy who's back to the bone
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
after we watch the horrifying scene in
which the riddler murders the mariners
on home we cut to the cityscape of
gotham to see the cesspool that it's
devolved into criminals occupy every
corner and we very much get the
impression that they've used the knight
as a weapon for decades in order to
terrorize the good people of the city
darkness clouds the entire landscape but
this is cracked open by the bat signal
which pierces the skyline after gordon
activates it we see it cuts through the
clouds and hovers over the landscape
standing as a beacon in the darkness
this is where we hear bruce's voice come
over the top of the scene and here he
introduces us to the city narration is
something that's often used in films to
set the tone and it's a staple that's
appeared in several detective noir
stories through it we very much get
bruises in her thoughts and how he not
only sees gotham but also the batman
it's a very effective technique and it
was used expertly in frank miller's dark
knight returns before he brought it over
to batman yet one we even get a shot in
the introduction where we catch bruce
and civilian clouds walking through a
crowd of people and this is very much
taken from year one when he went out on
his first night downtown in the movie
it's halloween and we see that the
streets are crowded with people in
costumes as the rain beats down on them
the only person who doesn't appear to be
in one is bruce who's wearing just a cap
raincoat and a cloth over his face
however as we see throughout the film
batman is the true face of bruce with a
public persona that he has being
somewhat of an afterthought man even
says [ __ ] bruce wayne at one point and
even when he goes to the funeral it's
clear he's completely checked out and
only in attendance because he thinks
that the riddler might be there he is
very much the mask that batman puts on
to go into the daylight and just in the
same way that these people that surround
bruce all wear costumes this is his
costume too bruce utters the line that
he's had two years of nights which is
turn him into a nocturnal animal and
when we see him later return to the cave
he's very much a broken man the batman
in this movie pretty much shows what
happens when you have no work like
balance but this dedication to his job
has also made him the most intimidating
figure in the film bruce is very much
like the terminator throughout and i
love how there's scenes in which he just
slowly walks towards people because he
knows there's no escape for them this is
very much done to put the fear of god
into his enemies and to let them know
that no matter what they can't get away
the guy will stalk you no matter what
and he's very much embodying what it's
like to be a nightmare horror movies for
decades have had slow lumbering villains
personified in the likes of michael
myers jason and it follows because
there's something far more intimidating
about shadow that moves towards you
slowly because it doesn't need to run it
shows it will get you and no matter how
much effort you put into trying to
escape you've got no chance of
outrunning it expertly shown at the end
of the car chase scene it's a motif
that's first brought up in this
introduction which we'll talk about in
just a bit
[Music]
whereas in the past we've tended to see
the streets through the eyes of citizens
and batman himself what reeves does
brilliantly here is that he shows us it
through the eyes of the criminals in
this we get several perspectives
including a drophead who robs a
convenience store a group of animals
spray painting what i believe are the
halls of justice and a gang that are
about to initiate a new member into
their ranks it's clear gotham is
teetering on the edge of the abyss and
in this darkness something new has come
forth now there's several fake outs in
the scene and we see how the criminals
very much live in fear that batman is
hiding in the shadows however like he
says he isn't hiding in the shadows he
is the shadows
i am wade because of this the criminals
feel like he could be around every
corner and he's very much become a part
of gotham it's a big city unlike batman
says he can't be everywhere however the
bat signal does a lot of the job for him
as it plants the idea in criminals minds
that he's out there and that he could be
coming for them
fear
is a tool
when that light hits the sky
[Music]
it's not just a call
a warning now this line gives me chills
and it shows how batman has very much
weaponized the bat signal to creep out
criminals so that they fear committing
crimes in case they run into the man
known as vengeance i love how we get
several fake out scenes such as the
drophead who looks down the dark
alleyway and stops what he's doing this
is a guy who's just robbed a convenience
store at gunpoint and in most instances
he'd think that a thief would want to
head to the darkest place they could
find in order to hide they'd want a
quick getaway which this would provide
but he stops and decides not to do it
just because the batman might be there
it's expert storytelling and it's
something that we can all relate to on
some level i'm guessing all of us at one
point in our lives have had to travel
home at night and we've ended up going
the long way round so that we don't have
to pass through a dark area the alleyway
or shortcut in the daytime might be well
lit and easy to go through but come
night it takes on a whole life of its
own it's the fear that something could
be lurking down there that makes us stop
what we're doing and like the thief go
the other way now luckily for this guy
batman isn't there and we discover that
he's been stalking the gang we watched
them through a dark and trained car and
then followed them out onto the platform
so that we can see them initiate their
new member happy attacking the public
they want to beat someone up but their
demeanor changes when they hear the slow
footsteps coming from the shadows much
like the ticking clock of the crocodile
in peter pan or the revving of the
batmobile later on there's something so
intimidating about hearing something
coming before it appears your mind
starts to race as you wonder what could
be making that sound and it's something
that was used expertly in the resident
evil 2 remake with mr x
as you move through the rpd you could
hear his footsteps pounding away and let
you know that he was out there you just
didn't know where matt reeves clearly
studied horror films in order to
determine what elements make us feel
most afraid and it's a stroke of genius
to film a character so steeped in fear
this way now at this point batman does
what you should do if you ever go to
prison and that is to beat up the leader
the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance
he completely and brutally kicks the
crap out of the gang's boss and much
like a prison let everyone know
i'm not locked in here with you
you're locked in here with me
it's an incredible move and from this
point on batman completely annihilates
the gang he leaves a new recruit alone
and due to this it's likely he'll never
turn to a life of crime again now this
actor actually plays robin in titans and
i think he'd also make for a great one
in the future of this franchise that is
if the mayor's son doesn't take the spot
getting off topic there but the idea
that batman is vengeance is first
introduced in this scene too and it's
something worth talking about after the
death of his parents he was very much on
a quest for revenge throughout the city
and he inadvertently learned that this
inspired the riddler bruce bumps into
one of his goons at the funeral for the
mayor and later when he's unmasked he
says the same thing this opening scene
very much sets up the arc that batman
goes on and there are several parallels
between himself and the riddler the
movie opens with edwards spying on the
mayor through binoculars and bruce later
does this with selena in her apartment
the two are both going after the corrupt
forces of gotham and they of course also
wear masks if you place the batman and
riddler one side by side you can even
see that the nose pieces are very
similar and all this has been done early
on so we can see that they mirror each
other it's expert filmmaking and it all
comes together from this introduction to
show us the effect that the batman has
on the city so that we can see how this
sphere might end up having a detrimental
effect all in all i absolutely love this
opening scene and it's something that
can be watched on its own without any
context surrounding it to show you why
the batman is such a highly loved
character hope you enjoyed our breakdown
of it and always
remember i am weed now if you enjoyed
the video then don't forget to hit the
thumbs up button as it really helps
breakdowns like this stand out and it
lets me know that you want to see more
things like this also make sure you
subscribe and on screen right now we
have a couple of videos for you to check
out discussing the batman make sure you
watch our full breakdown of the movie
and hopefully i'll see you over there
right after this hope you enjoyed the
rest of your week you take care yourself
i've been vengeance you've been the best
i'll see in the next one take care peace